hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in the first part of the sumatia logiai
question two Thomas Aquinas is
considering whether God exists and he
provides five ways quite famously for
leading a person to thinking that
something that we call God does in fact
exist and the first two ways have to do
with a certain range of causality the
Third Way also does deal with cause and
effect in certain ways so it's also a
causal argument based on some
metaphysical principles but also on
observation of what happens within the
world of our experience and this way you
could say is in a certain sense more
deeply metaphysical than the the first
two or at least it might be more obscure
and murky to some readers now he tells
us that this way is based on possibility
or sometimes it's translated as
contingency and necessity now that's a
very literal reading of what Thomas
Aquinas actually says
X possibility at NECA sario so
possibility and necessity are built into
the very framing you could say of the
proof now not everybody translates it
that way sometimes you can find for
example in the black Friars the Third
Way is based on what need not be and on
what must be but those are
circumlocutions you might say that I
think that the translator thought would
be helpful but I think are actually a
little bit misleading for what's
possible and what is necessary what is
necessary has to be what it is or as it
is right what's possible can be or not
be or can change as we're going to find
out when he brings up some general
examples
now this proof is also a little bit more
complicated than the others because
there's really two arguments connected
together that are going on the one
supplies the beginning place for the
second argument the one has to do with
the movement from possibility to
necessity and then the other one has to
do with different necessary things and
how they are arranged so he tells us
that we encounter right in venimous in
things in the universe in what we
observe some things that uh can be and
not be quite soon possibilia
and so he's going to use as an example
of this
um when we find things springing up and
dying away again
right and so by consequence to be and
not to be so you know human beings
plants books all these things can come
into existence they don't have to
necessarily exist you and I are
contingent or possible you know if our
parents my parents your parents hadn't
gotten together in the time and way that
they did you wouldn't exist I wouldn't
exist right somebody else would exist in
our place or maybe nobody would exist
coming from them right or maybe lots of
people would exist your mom you know I
had a whole bunch of kids with somebody
else and your dad had a whole bunch of
kids with somebody else you get the
point right so we encounter a lot of
things that could be or or not be right
it's possible for them to
exist or not we're not yet at the point
of necessity because we could say
how many things
could it be the case
that everything is merely possible
there's no necessary being in existence
and here's where Thomas is going to make
a very interesting argument which you
might not entirely Buy
so he says it can't be the case that
everything is of this sort namely uh
merely possible impossibilities he says
um why because that which is possible to
not be right
um at some point in time isn't so
possibilia known as uh
uh
um
is how he's saying it Ali cuando means
at some time and
um you know so if if indeed everything
is merely possible
then at some point in time
there's nothing
now you might say well why does that
have to be the case well think of
infinite possibilities
right Thomas isn't actually running
through this but you could like do a
kind of combinatorics with this kind of
in your head obviously you're not going
to carry out the entire operation of
thinking about every single thing that
not only is an existence but ever has
been or will be in existence but you
could like think about all the
possibilities and there's one
possibility that has nothing sort of
like it was in set theory we call the
empty set right
now if that's the case here's where
causality comes in
well you don't get anything from nothing
nothing is not a cause of anything so
like he says it would be impossible that
anything could begin to be impossible
to begin essay and so everything uh
nothing would be the case right you
could say the totality would be nothing
and he says well
that's clearly false because you know I
exist you exist things that we see in
the world exist so clearly they didn't
come from nothing so there must be
something that always has to be the case
that always has to exist and that's
something necessary aliquid necessarium
right so we know that there's at least
one necessary being in existence now
some people might stop there and say aha
we've got God Thomas does not stop there
why not
because he knows that there are multiple
necessary things in the nature of
whatever we want to call it the totality
the whole in Rebus to use his phrase
that he comes back to over and over
again
how would we differentiate
different Necessary Things
well one thing we can do and here's
where we come to causes again is ask
yourself the question
does the necessary thing have its cause
of its necessity now notice he doesn't
just say the cause of its existence the
cause of its necessity in itself or in
something else some other necessary
being because you're not going to get it
from some possible being and so he says
that
um you know everything that is necessary
either has the cause of its necessity
from something else or it doesn't so
have it and can we like say well
this thing over here let's call it a
necessity a has its cause in necessity B
which has its cause in necessity C could
we proceed as he says to infinity here's
where it looks a lot like the first and
second ways doesn't it and he says no
you can't do that when it comes to the
cause of necessity any more than you can
in uh efficient causality as we've
already proven just above right and so
therefore he says we must or it's
necessary to
um posit pornery sat down
something that is necessary through
itself or by itself however we want to
translate per se Ali quid we asked per
se
something we don't quite know yet what
exactly this is but we're saying hey you
can't trace it back odd infinitum
through you know into Infinity so
there's got to be something absolutely
necessary we might say right so he says
that it doesn't have its cause of its
own necessity in anything else but
it is the cause of it the others
necessity
now notice what he doesn't say at the
very end of this that he said in the
other two and all people call this all
people understand this to be God we're
supposed to read that in there that this
ultimately
necessary being that is the cause of all
the other necessary beings necessity
um
is the cause of itself and this would be
the highest the Supreme namely God now
one other thing I do want to point out
before we close this out
this is a very very interesting argument
because there's kind of I won't say a
metal level but there's certainly uh use
of the very Concepts that are being
explored
within the argument itself some things
are not possible Right some things are
possible the possibility of all things
being possible turns out to be a
non-possibility right an impossibility
so we've got these very interesting what
we nowadays call modal concepts of
necessity impossibility possibility
contingency at play Within the very
proof itself so arguing our way to a
completely necessary being the cause of
other necessary beings is carried out by
argumentation that Thomas himself thinks
is itself necessary in some way he's or
at least the argumentation invokes
necessity and impossibility